we got the kopar s for match up here in the early
going big pass for Str shoots tal to stop on that
tereno LS that back Bernard d a along shot that's
gloved by talber centerman well you sometimes you
got to win physical battles and here he is Philip
Den No or Mike Anderson going to hit him spins
off him takes it gets to a better spot and just a
shot there you have to engage physically and win
some of those battles hiala back for dowy back
for fiala Center a copar hard shot kicked out
by another shot of the go pun go fala for all the
assists fala can really rip it Downy back to fiaa
to kopar looking for that kopar bump and fiaa shot
was blocked by ham you play back can't be a quick
shot T SA TR wi and Sanderson sends it down the
ice that's a big Jordan Spence with it speaking of
Australia Spence plays it across the pfield fence
was born in Australia Liv in Japan and he was 13
pfield shoots that's blocked by Bernard Docker
Byfield Fe it down again with a sto rebound score
do know gets his own rebound flips it by Corpus
Salo who made the great initial stop and the King
strike on the power play to make it one- nothing
La attacks from different spots whether it's shots
from up top of the circle or plays down low first
one's blocked and the quick little bump pass in
there to den and clevin gets stuck with his feet
on the goal crease and he's trying to protect back
door but he's already got support back there
needs to step a bit closer to the know take
that shot [Music] away winds his way up jaob CHR
placs it across the B and walks right and shoots
at the goal post drive by ch he takes his Puck
activates he doesn't want to dump but he drives
right towards the defense gets the no to commit
and that opens up BS Roy just keeps backing up out
gabov stuck there and what a nice shot just Rings
the barado a sharp angle shot that's fired wide by
K shman back for it plays it back around was
picked off by kopar Cent's reir PS it back
acoss by Camp can't believe he miss how did he
miss that when you got an open look oh off the
post and out Sanderson beats it back to St down
to J Feed it back to kachuck in the side that
rebound and kachuck slams his stick to the net in
frustration he had a great look as it was Landing
it oh what a pass from geru down to teraso teraso
drops it back to Bernard Docker now bouncing puck
in front the Dig away for it and back cathers
turned away again by talin getting pucks down
below the goal line working for position and
taken to the net that's a nice seal off by BS
he need that little flip in the Box to start
the second so ottawa's had lots of great looks
here and SP drops it back Sanderson in shoots T
at the same point blank on Jake Sanderson he is
so serious when he plays here's the latest great
look that's Sanderson from almost the hash mark
chck little between the legs pass for Joseph back
to Ticker he's got room shoot that's block to with
a Chance Byfield steps up calls for the puck kopar
send to the hand Byfield in on the breakway roll
that wide here he is late in a power penalty kill
card how's your bank shot he's been playing cool
his whole life five tries go back hand and the
Chuck was looking for the Home Run pass there
just look knocked down at Center Ice the faier
moves it a cross hard shot there the pat stop
by cor pasal there's the Miss there's the crossy
pass late in the ship never a great idea because
of it Corell forced to make that stop looks at
to Norris to Josh Norris comes up with it pops
back to PS p ticken down there by Grunst and play
continues Kay Works in on cleven swings it back
across with some scores and just like that the
Kings go up the ice and make it a two nothing
lead l of walk to the races here bson picks
up this Puck you got to make a good decision
as you have a defense activating and then
terko who had crashed into the linesman was
changing and Kelly can't quite get back
to the three on two and you're wondering
where do everyone go well this is why tereno
he goes in heavily and he's slow to get off
atalo doesn't realize that he's up ice turnover
I'm calling the upward climb over for this year
here's egland firit escap from rebound score
hook home by Kopitar and that's Travis hamik
took that shot in the foot the goal is bad
enough but the hamic injury would be worse
and he's trying to get up three guys and quit
Byfield and Byfield comes up with it what an
effort able to get to the far side and and then
while H by cabinet goes down in pain poar is
able to grab the loose Pucket sweep at home and
Travis havick becomes the third autoa Senator
to head to the dressing room tonight tonight
they are getting along they they care right
you're going to have blowups you shoes picked
up by Corel another chance on the goal post by
theier in comes Matthew Joseph with it punched
along the board so back at the point is CH feads
it back to tereno to CH cross he goes to jaru
jeru Cent K scores there it is a power play
goal 20 seconds to go in the second period and 's
back in [Music] itally we seen him playing Chicago
Detroit he can absolutely rip it so get him in
the shooting spot and he's right there little
pop pass no mistake Joseph in front he get that
one up really well from a shot that oh straight
lefi still 21 these are still very young players
you're talking about England to Lewis and Spence
centers a tipped on goal by grun from great save
there by Corpus Sal Spence working down the wall
finding a stick for a tip and you're right Corpus
Alo had to be quick and spot that deflection and
it's hard to execute but they do it really well
now Byfield works drops for the trailer K shoots
cor Mell say oh the rebound took it away what a
stop there by cor Mell yeah you want to move your
feet you feel a stick on your body get away from
iton drops it back Bernard Docker swings that back
to Tero shoot Kar the face and Kar slowly going
back to the LA B being hit with that Pock doer
shoots might have been deflected in front
but Bernard Docker at this St has his first
and it's goal but I think noris got a pie
bench yelling for a whistle I I agree them
not blowing it down because while it hurts
kopar wasn't in danger of hurting himself
and as he limped off became a power play Josh
nor standing open in front comes it back to Mo
fala walks it and shoots boun up left by the play
back across hand rebal he could have two or three
another tremendous save by Corpus Sal and his
crazy scramble in front fow's got an empty net
third per goal by Josh Norris a up back to
one in comes more with a Chance shoots and
cor shuts that down that pass knocked down by
teraso he finds Norris otwa busting in three
wide teraso back door pass oh just missed that
took the mask of talet on 32 here in the third
period pressing for the equalizer on Canadian
Tires Center his hockey more tied up there by
Sanderson off back Spence miss that shot oh
R go a kick there by Den a save by cor pasalo
final seconds now the period Ottawa gets back on
side fired down by Norris stla goes after it Tim
stla tries to center it that skips wide and
the LA Kings win it by a final score of 3-2